well since was a big wrestling fan what
did you think of Ronda Rousey and the
rumble shown up and yeah showing up and
just being in well you know it's
probably gonna have program with Oscar
because Oscar is undefeated all right
okay I guess someone comes in watch rest
I have to like I sort of have to like no
I don't have well I don't have cable
anymore
yeah so I watch it on Hulu they have the
WWE you know you can watch their shows
on Hulu and you can get through them
kind of quick I kind of just want to
know what they're doing you know there
are some things in wrestling where I
kind of like well I can tell you what
their fake wrestling always okay I mean
that's not I mean no I mean they're
yelling at each other so that's what
they're doing no it is really that word
for that as nothing well Bryan would
someone call the great works of
Shakespeare nothing well now it would
someone call and she looks forward to
winning at all and my friend said but
it's a play so hard to play that's like
how do you win at all yeah although she
looks adorable there I think she's just
looking really really cute um I'll tell
you this right now you know she'll
probably win whatever the heck her first
matches but then what they do she got to
give it back you know what I mean really
she well she's got a she's got a give
back they hate the throng no I'm saying
she's got to like give back the the
victory now you know those acts and
that's how people you stay interested
they go who you know money her even
though you asked me for money sometimes
I've never asked you for money sir
please no money please if you take that
back well you have them you have not to
spread rumors but no I'm a different you
have a drug problem I do have a [ __ ]
heavy drug yeah so let me ask you this
that's why you're wearing dentures right
now but let me ask you this here check
this out Oh God here's my Shane McKellen
ah in the gallon Shane MacGowan Shane
MacGowan
him again kind of money you think she's
making for this [ __ ] do I know what the
[ __ ] would I know how much they make I
don't know a few hundred K or a million
bucks I don't [ __ ] know a lot of
money look at how many people are
slaughtered the way she's Ronda Rousey
alright she's got a t-shirt on like
hot
Rowdy Roddy Piper she looks at but it
says hot Rhonda she's a cutie pie I love
her she is a cutie pie they're all cutie
pies and now you've never been to a
wrestling event no I read and also I
when you go when you go and you sit up
close it's so you see how the how they
could so easily get hurt which I would
follow up with if I were Bryan Callen
for nothing and it's so easy for them to
get hurt and like the the gal on the
right in the last picture there mmm
this that's a little girl it's a little
girls little yeah tiny thing just I
remember going like a thing and you see
these these you know women going all out
because it's a big event and you just
like you're doing a lot of yeah and I
did the same thing I remember when we
went and when we watched Brendan fight
in vancouver and i sat there at cage
side going yeah you know what well I'm
trying to say I said and they all say
that the injury rate is crazy like it's
it is not easy
you got to be an athlete to be in the
you also have to know you also have to
have a dance partner knows what they're
doing or else someone's gonna get hurt
people get hurt bottom line is Brian
yeah I want to speak to this as far as a
wrestling fans yourself and walk to me
and mixed martial arts all right you
know our dear pal Brendan in the middle
of a high train is about literally
reading life and life life and death so
condescending okay I said I train but
you can't let me dump I finish what I'm
saying don't shush me it's so obnoxious
a anything else something I'm saying all
I said was in passing I train as well
don't hold on let me finish okay let me
feel this you know cuz I can hear it
even though don't talk if you tie I can
do my podcast okay I said you're gonna
hear all I said was I trained you see
let me finish what I'm saying all right
but don't coach okay don't talk fine
I train quiet right now all right let me
finish
okay here's the thing you're talking I'm
trying to finish
all right okay now I I have the same you
talking still you are not a lot don't ya
listen I have the same reaction whether
it's Ronda Rousey in a you know in a
leather coat yeah and a little Alexa
bliss over there slamming each other
around and doing their dance right sure
as I do
to Brendan in a life-and-death battle
you know in a real fight right real
fight in the cage UFC I mean and to even
to be that close to it man oh man it's
that's a different puts a different
paint job on things let me tell you and
it's the exact same reaction for me why
is that why cuz I Shh
I told you to shut the [ __ ] up because I
have I have what's called an imagination
okay now when you have an imagination
yeah I have an imagination too
you know a lot of people watch mixed
martial arts or combat sports like this
you know whether it's boxing kickboxing
karate calendar you know I'm Alan dough
is right
nope just wits when a guy's one of 51
year old guy sits in the middle of a mat
tries to get hard not just I've never
done that dude really I've never sat in
the middle of a mat and tug my putt
especially a challenge oh you know what
I would love to see you do what I would
love you I would love to see you walk
out in front of a small group of pay a
small paying audience yeah you know in
Cambodia or something why in a ring when
they're making you know they got food
running around they got people serving
food and they're fat and you know how
they have like yeah they got bets going
and there's just like you know music
fight before that I'd better remain two
animals two different animals who
roosters yeah every now may be a hyena
maybe three roosters or just one dog and
two wild dogs yeah that would be good
yeah anything really a ferret versus a
jellyfish some weird [ __ ] sure that
stuff yeah and then the main event Brian
you come out in really short Muay Thai
shorts yeah right and then you whip them
off put that award down sit on it get it
up your ass
try to get hard in the middle
[ __ ] room this is [ __ ] well I
don't [ __ ] you think I have the [ __ ] you
think you are love that's a mixed
martial never do that I'm not that guy
I'd pay pay-per-view money for gave a
[ __ ] what you'd pay I would never do
that I would love to see walking out in
Cambodia after all these animals have
been fighting yet and I'm not walking
out there 51 yeah
pulling down my super really short
shorts my time and then sitting on that
this thing's just a war that says best
woman I'm not sittin on that [ __ ]
yeah and getting your brown balloon not
all around that and sitting on it you
really brought this podcast down until I
was up into your large intestine I'm not
doing that [ __ ] you a bigger award I'll
get you out tell you what well I'll get
you an Eiffel Tower now you know from
I'm gonna get you a bunch of every time
I'm in an airport I'm gonna get you
something that we can put up your ass
well you try to get your flaccid fish
dick hard in front of people eating you
know don't call it flat king and what's
the other thing larb that's chicken larb
that's all ty you're being you're
assuming that I find it more offensive
that you're assuming that Cambodian
cuisine is the same as Thai cuisine
never see more offensive okay so name
one Cambodian car what's your favorite
what's your favorite Cambodian [ __ ]
you're too ignorant to even know what it
is I can tell you what it is because
I've spent time in that part of the
world and I have great deal respect for
for all different kinds of essentially
cuisine you know what mine is what mung
bean black bean and who can stop right
there because mung bean belongs to to
Vietnam okay to the Hmong people no okay
that that was so easy and you don't
animate an [ __ ] no black beans
because that belongs to make equal so at
the end of the day you're not waiting to
and I felt very offensive uh one of my
favorite Cambodian dishes yeah go ahead
the Cambodian BLT
that what is that though what's in it
it's good you're making it up see all
right you're already pausing it's got
goat bacon no goat there and there's no
coke bacon
make bacon out a go uh goddamnit river
lettuce zero okay wait a minute
River lettuce you mean the Lily that
kind of like the vegetation that sort of
floats on the top of the rail Rio it
spoken like a man who's been to Cambodia
finally yeah but they I don't think you
can eat those that's that's giant lily
pads yeah and then and then you know
just your basic hothouse tomato on toast
well there's no Toyo's in that's in the
new world so that doesn't belong to
Cambodia so well what do you mean tomato
as far as tomatoes like tomatoes the
little ones that grow on the ground some
nice vine tomatoes same as you get at
Ralph's or Cambodia not in Cambodia I
don't think so oh I guess I guess the
last time I was in Cambodia in a
restaurant eating a Cambodian BLT
watching you get your puckered [ __ ]
my life your dick hard
nope I must have just been hallucinating
yeah yeah sure brings me back to my
point well I can watch you know some
mixed martial arts happen I can watch
some wrestling or ever you want to call
it happen and it's just it's all an
enchantment of the mind for me because I
have what's called an imagination serves
me well so I am fan of wrestling still I
like their colorful outfits and
personalities like it when they say I'm
gonna win no I'm gonna win and then you
watch it and then Vince McMahon has
decided who's gonna win and then you
okay then you see that so it's fixed the
old thing is basically good the way God
it kind of has already decided your
destiny and you can do everything you
want you know at the end of the day
you're still gonna burn the lake of fire
if you're will sasso right well you're
off you're even more on the next believe
it's better the next get out of here so
I can get out of here I gotta get the
fungus back back to the airport and fly
you know you've made me so sick I'm
gonna fly back to Canada Wow what's
Canadiens leverage you because you're
Canadian
I'm also America not really don't take
out I don't care about your passport I
don't I don't want to see it that's a
forgery not gonna look at it tell you
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]